hi I'm Mike Matheny I've been part of
some great clubs and now I'm part of
another just as one of the oldest and I
believe most beneficial sports you can
be involved in I have witnessed and
experienced the tremendous value the st.
Louis chess campus is brought to our
community it is this reason that I chose
to become a founding member of the Chi
ISA Club the Chi ISA club is a joint
gift program between the chess club and
scholastic center of st. Louis and the
World Chess Hall of Fame recognizing
dedicated individuals corporations and
foundations who make an annual gift of a
thousand dollars or more to the chi-you
circle as a donor you will help sustain
chest through education the arts culture
competition and its history in the city
of st. Louis and ile saint-louis is the
chess capital of the United States and
the sport has been introduced to
thousands of children throughout the
region your donation will assist in
supporting children in hundreds of
schools preserving the history of the
game in showcasing its cultural and
artistic significance through
world-class exhibitions
join me as a member of the Chi asa club
to help lead in getting the results our
children in this city deserve for more
information and membership benefits go
to st. Louis chess club org